j'avais eu l'idée donc de d'essayer de
m'autoremplacer de voir dans quelle
mesure je pouvais m'autoremplacer
j'avais écrit des livres d'histoire
traditionnels auparavant sur l'Antiquité
romaine et euh je voulais voir donc
étant fasciné par cette technologie si
on pouvait écrire un livre d'un type
nouveau avec euh avec un modèle de
langage euh l'idée étant pas en réalité
de vraiment me remplacer je voulais pas
faire simplement automatiser ce que je
pouvais déjà faire euh à la main ou avec
le cerveau si si jeose dire je voulais
faire quelque chose que je ne pouvais
pas faire autrement en tout cas de
différent de ce que j'aurais fait sans
cette technologie et euh comm un des
principaux défauts on va en parler au
fur et à mesure des grands modèles de
langage c'est que par leur structure
même ils sont incapables de vérifier la
véracité de leurs information et de ce
qu'il raconent pour faire de l'histoire
c'était pas terrible parce que
évidemment on risque à chaque instant
d'avoir des fausses informations des
inventions des des hallucinations comme
on dit et donc je me suis orienté vers
une nucronie donc d'imaginer justement
ce qui ne s'est pas passé et l'histoire
si elle avait enfin telle qu'elle aurait
pu être si un événement avait changé et
là au contraire la capacité enfin plutôt
le ce défaut des modèles de langage qui
consiste à inventer euh ce qu'il ne ce
qu'ils ne savent pas devient plutôt un
avantage parce que on il s'agit de
stimuler la créativité et donc d'essayer
de générer des idées de d'histoire qui
ne s'est pas passé donc voilà c'est
comme ça que j'en suis venu à à écrire
ce livre qui est en fait composé à la
fois de de d'une réie narratif où je
guide lia pour voir essayer d'imaginer
ce qui aurait pu se passer dans un
empire romain qui aurait connu justement
des avancées technologiques
importantes et ensuite je commente
moi-même en reprenant la plume ce que ça
ce que ça nous dit alors d'un point de
vue historien si c'est vraisemblable ou
pas et ensuite ce que ça peut nous
enseigner sur justement l'utilisation de
l' sur sur ce que ça promet pour la
recherche la réflexion et la création